e aí
e a vela velejar são tantas variáveis
tem um mar as ondas a corrente as marés
a intensidade do vento a mudança do
vento a escolha do seu equipamento para
velejar a regulagem do barco os
competidores a sua interação de grupo
abordo a tática de regata são muitas
variáveis é um esporte lindo com nove
anos eu estava em brasília e tava
correndo uma das minhas primeiras
regatas estava indo super bem cheio de
amigos a vela só que o vento rondônia
essa regata e o vento rondou e eu fiquei
em último mas não foi o último foi
realmente o último lá atrás e eu me
lembro de ter começado a chorar a bordo
desesperada com aquela situação uma
certa vergonha poxa meus coleguinhas
estavam lá na frente
oi tia será que eu desisto dessa regata
será que eu continuo que que eu devo
fazer agora eu enfrentei aquele medo e
aquela vergonha eu resolvi não eu vou
até o final talvez nem deu tempo de eu
continuar porque o juiz de regata às
vezes esperavam né tem um tempo limite
para você completar regata e eu resolvi
completar aquela regata e foi indo tô
indo aí até que eu cruzei a linha e o
gostinho de chegar não foi gosto no
último foi o gostinho de não desistir e
ali eu comecei aprender um pouquinho
sobre uma coisa que eu vou falar aqui
que é o espírito vencedor eu abracei o
meu pai naquele momento e comemorei
aquela regata muito tempo depois
pequim-2008 olimpíadas de pequim-2008
nós estávamos preparadas temos treinado
muito muita gente não acreditava que a
gente conseguisse chegar no pódio na
olimpíada mas a gente sabia que é
o primeiro dia de regata penúltimo eu me
lembro naquele dia em pequim a gente
voltando aquela regata com aquele sabor
amargo de frustração na boca aquele sol
laranja chinês voltando rebocado pelo
meu técnico uma vontade de brigar com
uma vontade de discutir mas a gente
conseguiu se recompor conversar aquela
noite e focar no objetivo e aí o dia
seguinte a gente ficou em 14º lugar no
outro dia em nono lugar vamos subindo na
súmula no outro em quarto chegamos para
regata da medalha a medal race em
terceiro lugar fizemos uma regata linda
passando barcos e chegamos na primeira
posição conquistando a primeira medalha
olímpica da história feminina do brasil
foi um momento de materializações foi um
momento de ter certeza
e de fazer está fazendo a coisa certa e
hoje eu tô aqui depois de quatro
campanhas olímpicas de ter ganhado de
ter perdido eu quero mostrar para vocês
tudo que eu aprendi dentro da água a
primeira edição é que plano é muito
importante toda vez que eu fui velejar
sem um plano sem testar linha de largada
sem decidir se eu ia para a direita ou
para esquerda sem decidir sem testar meu
equipamento nossa o resultado não vinha
mas quando eu me preparava e realmente
decidir e definir um plano em momentos
de pressão durante a competição é muito
mais fácil tomar uma decisão você tem um
pano ali te dando aquela base então essa
é a primeira lição a segunda edição é
que cada ponto importa é muito
importante fazer bem feito e tentar
passar
e sempre cada ponto importa na olimpíada
do rio aqui na raia da ponte ponte
rio-niterói aqui atrás corremos numa
condição de vento oeste que não é muito
comum tv oeste aqui vento forte e a
gente virou na regata na olimpíada do
rio 2016 conseguimos desvirar o barco
rapidamente ainda passamos barcos e eu
senti que ter passado o barco foi o
passaporte para a gente entrar para
regata final e ser finalista na
olimpíada do rio de janeiro são tantos
tantos outros exemplos onde o empate o
desempate aquele pontinho fez toda a
diferença outra lição não olhar para
trás se você olha para trás e fica preso
nos erros que você cometeu no passado
que você cometeu atrás na regata você
não vai para frente você não consegue
focar no presente diante de tantas
variáveis que a vela tem então teve uma
rede
e no mundial em 2011 em perth na
austrália que a gente estava em segundo
lugar disputando país italianas e as
italianos começaram a olhar para trás
começar a perder a rajada e a gente
descendo cada onda que a gente foi
ficando mais forte mais forte tava
chegando a linha de chegada e a gente
foi conseguindo passar no limite ali a
gente passou por quê porque a gente
estava energizado vindo vendo que elas
não estavam concentradas no presente e a
gente conseguiu ganhar uma regata que
para mim foi muito importante porque
essa campanha eu tive pouquíssimo apoio
de confederação e fiz basicamente muita
força sozinha também de administração
fora d'água mas o que eu realmente
aprendi durante esses quase 16 anos
velejando
se é que o espírito vencedor tem que
estar sempre dentro de você e é muito
fácil falar de espírito vencedor quando
você tá ganhando a regata porque o vento
tá mais limpo né a bordo o clima é muito
melhor tá tudo ótimo agora eu quero ver
manter o espírito vencedor quando você
tá atrás da regata isso eu demorei
aprender porque eu ficava reclamando
mudando para trás focada nos meus erros
e isso não pode acontecer porque você
deixa de prestar atenção no presente e
você o seu presente fica pior que você
não consegue passar barcos e com
maturidade com tempo eu mudei
completamente agora é foco total no
presente fazendo o seu melhor e a
é lógico temos que comemorar cada
vitória
e eu acabei de vir agora de mundial york
ande a gente fez o índice olímpico mas a
gente não teve o melhor resultado mas
teve um dia que a gente recebeu um
prêmio a gente foi o barco mais rápido
no vento em popa no campeonato mundial e
eu sei o que significa isso significam
vários rostos muito indicado no barco eu
tô falando de um barco com a velocidade
mais rápida do olimpíadas no fórum e
para mim eu saboreei aquilo com gostinho
de vitória muito grande
e eu acho que na vida às vezes os ventos
são favoráveis às vezes eles são
desfavoráveis mas o espírito vencedor
tem que ser intocável ele não deve mudar
e a gente não deve olhar para o passado
deixar que os erros do passado
influencia em nosso presente da o melhor
agora prestar atenção e tudo cada
pontinho importa e com certeza o futuro
vai ser brilhante
e aí
[Música]